there was one NFL story that kind of
flew under the radar because everybody
was paying attention to what Trump was
saying okay there's another NFL story
that I noticed that I think we should
talk about in Tom Brady's new book he
says that drinking a lot of water
prevents sunburns that's what he says
yes now I'm not making this up Tom Brady
says that if you drink enough water you
will not get sunburns now do not get me
wrong I'm a huge Patriots fan and I'm a
Tom Brady fan I'm from Boston but that
doesn't sound right to me whoa whoa
watch your mouth oh now I'm sorry what
is it who said that yeah
Conan are you calling Tom Brady Alya you
you you callin on Tommy a lie Oh Brian
can we just guess you guys are Tom Brady
friends right yeah you're damn right
Conan I'm Tom O'Donnell and I'm Danny
O'Donnell hey hey um Brady is a god
you're damn right dumb thanks Donny okay
listen guys Tom Brady's great but in
this case his advice is just that wrong
no no no no Conan it's simple science
you put water on a fire it goes out
right
Yeah right I guess yeah it's the same
thing you drink a lot of water it puts
out this skin fire Donny's right thanks
Dom no I'm telling you that's not how it
works guys sure it does we were at the
beach all day yesterday drank plenty of
water we didn't even use any sunscreen
and look how sunburned you guys are
we're not burned
we're red because we're embarrassed for
you nice one God thanks Connie see that
see that even your hands you're
sunburned no doll that was just that's
patriots passion go Pat's
hey guys you can't get your health
advice from sports legends no matter how
big a fan you are okay sure we can okay
look perfect example remember that time
Larry Bird said to eat more pine cones
no I don't remember that no well we did
you know we both wound up in the
hospital and we both ended up marrying
hot nurses yeah Thank You Larry may you
rest in peace guys Larry Bird is still
alive
you guys need to listen to doctors not
athletes
hey if that doctor has five Super Bowl
rings I'm all he is in the meantime we
got to go refill a lotta bottles eleven
more gallons to go
thank you
now we're so would come out and hand me
roses right thank you thank you very
much
you